et puis on vous l'annonca lundi le Grand
Théâtre de tour vient d'être classé
monument historique dans son entièreté
alors qu'auparavant seul quatre parti le
grand escalier la salle de spectacle le
foyer et le péristyle étaient classé une
très bonne nouvelle car grâce à ce
nouveau classement les travaux de
rénovation sont envisageables puisqu'il
ouvre la porte à de nouvelles
subventions de l'État or l'opéra de tour
a justement besoin d'être rajeuni et
remise au norme
regardez sa façade N pas été modifié
depuis le 19e siècle l'opéra de tour
monument emblématique de la ville fait
la fierté des tourangeau mais ceux qui
s'y sont déjà rendu le constate le
bâtiment et ses équipements vieillissent
à l'intérieur a pas mal de fissures mais
à l'extérieur je sais pas j'ai vu qu'il
y avait un filet là-haut donc la
dernière fois je suis passée je crois
qu'il y avait des hommes qui étaient en
train de réparer c'est un beau monument
on s'étonne simplement du fait que les
portes n'aient pas été repeintes on sait
pas pourquoi il y a toujours cette
vieille peinture abîmée ces altérations
du aut temp pourrait bientôt être de
l'histoire ancienne avec son nouveau
classement aux monuments historiques
l'opéra de tour espère pouvoir mener une
grande campagne de restauration
accompagné des meilleurs artisans
spécialistes il y a un immense cahier
des charges qui va devoir être mis en
place qui va comporter des milliers de
points de la réparation de tête fissure
à la mise en norme en sécurité de tel de
tel passage à la restauration de du
lustre bon et bien cet immense cahé des
charges va être écrit va devoir être
écrit ça va être un énorme travail puis
qu'il va concerner chaque pièce chaque
couloir chaque chaque salle de cette de
cette maison car le bâtiment n'a pas
connu de grand plan de rénovation depuis
1889 date de réouverture après un
incendie spectaculaire en 1883 qui avait
ravagé l'intérieur de l'édifice parmi
les travaux nécessaires donc nettoyer la
fresque de l'escalier réagrandir la
fusse d'orchestre ou encore consolider
la scène plus adapté aux toiles peintes
sur châssis du 19e siècle qu'au décor
actuel plus lourd son sans oublier le
rafraîchissement de la salle de
spectacle il y a beaucoup de choses dans
la dans la salle qui sont dégradé qui
ont été dégradé par le temps par l'usure
donc ici par exemple c'est le moins
technique mais ça va être le plus
visible pour notre public on va changer
les sièges évidemment et on va redonner
à cette salle un côté un petit peu plus
luxueux un tout petit peu plus agréable
que ce que le temps malheureusement a
[Musique]
fait l'opéra espère aussi pouvoir
s'agrandir pour améliorer le confort de
ces équipes administratives qui sont à
l'étroit et se doter d'un second plateau
pour les répétition un équipement qui
permettrait de moins mobiliser la scène
et donc d'élargir la
programmation